hey so I'm gonna tell you story
basically be me download see if RS to
use in your Park and then you place a
CFR and it's 2 CFR that you've already
placed like 10 meters away from that one
and I didn't even realize so yeah this
little custom flat right over there it's
obvious it's obviously one that I
already placed in my pike I have no idea
why I place that thing again i forgot
that I place there was something i was
just like hey i might as well place that
but that just was a waste of time so i
have to remove that thing later on but
anyway it's time to finish this area so
i just decided that's going to be fences
right because i don't know but for some
reason my brain just can't rest unless
all of the path work is looking ok
that's the point where i can move on to
general stuff around paths i have no
idea the only problem with this area is
that it's really hard to get a sort of
general idea because i'm still not
really sure about things for example
these little things in the middle
because on one hand I don't want this
entire area to be path obviously because
not a big fan of big paths and it just
looks empty and stuff like that but then
again that you have those little areas
over there and I don't want to place too
much foliage in it because then it would
block the skyline of the buildings so I
think I'm just gonna end up adding
flowers or something in those things I
haven't really done I haven't really
done too much with flowers as of lately
and I do love those things so yeah might
as well move on with that but then i was
already bored so i was like hey I'm just
gonna be on there built on buildings
again because that's also necessary and
yeah these towers are just going to be
very similar to the first hour of course
they're going to be slightly different
and I definitely did not want to
copy-paste anything I don't think
anything is paste copy pasted in this
park which is a kind of an achievement
I'd say because usually I like copy
pasting some things especially when
building towers of skyscrapers but not
happening today and yeah so these towers
are going to be awfully similar but not
exactly the same so it's still going to
have a similar effect but you know I
generally recommend to not copy and
paste anything copy keep it as minimal
as you can of course I said that I
sometimes copy and paste skyscrapers
and yeah that makes sense as long as the
floors are the same and as long as
something is the same and it's meant to
be the same author out the thing
whatever it may be then it might be okay
to copy and paste things but its
buildings with loads of different
details you shouldn't copy and paste
that you should never ever copy paste
foliage even though it might save you so
much time it's just going to look less
natural in the end and other things are
generally only copy paste of all you
can't just copy paste paths that's no
way that's going to work out with all
the curves and stuff like that so I
suppose you shouldn't really worry too
much about that but although I like the
feature in roller coaster tycoon 3 it
does take away a bit of realism some
time so I like to keep it minimal but of
course I also like to save myself some
time so sometimes it really does come in
handy but anyway I think I am definitely
digressing at this point yeah well then
again these houses are awfully similar
to the towers that I've placed before
hmm also have I set yet this is not
going to be a small and large episode as
you can obviously tell by the time
they're just nine minutes I don't know
if I actually want to make these episode
longer episodes longer or shorter
because right now I every time lapse is
about one hour and 40 minutes to two
hours worth of time-lapse footage and
I'm not really sure if I want to make
that longer or shorter probably not sure
to but I'm not too sure about the
nine-minute long time lapses but oh well
I think I'll just keep it like this
because it's nice for me as well because
i don't i don't have to spend too much
time behind my computer not doing
anything else and i don't have to spend
too much time commentating over it
because after a while i also just kind
of calm down and I don't know that's a
good thing or a bad thing but I suppose
it's not an amazing thing and I think
this is kind of an okay length but I
might make some longer episodes and if I
do real-time episodes which I might do a
ton point again then I am definitely
going to make longer episodes
but so far I suppose I'm content with
the length of them and this is all just
more details shenanigans though that was
mobis something that I added at that
point because I just felt like I would
have base walls everywhere I didn't even
know if this is realistic but I just
have a base wall fetish in the game you
might as well say that because every
building needs a base walk I mean of
course buildings have foundations but i
am not even entirely sure whether every
single building should and would have a
baseball but I just like the look of it
so I'd say go for it least that's what I
like to do and then I had windows
shenanigans again because that there is
this problem and i'm sure i've talked
about this earlier on but it just keeps
bugging me it's the fact that station
gyms window are amazing i can just place
them and be like hi yes and then i can
just freeze the game and just look at it
look at that window and admire it but
then again i zoom out and the windows
gone and that just irritates me because
they're so amazing but then again i
can't use them because the render
distance is too damn small so there's no
real way to fix that so i just i just
decided to go with I mean these are
stationed Jim's windows of course in 0
geez things but it's not quite the same
and then there is a catfish Cove which
also has some really nice windows I
suppose that catfish Cove despite not
reeling not really meant for that it's
kind of the SATs for the windows for the
Alpine series because the alpine village
series only have a couple of good
windows and i usually use the UN dos in
catfish code for all my alpine buildings
but as you see also for my other types
of buildings because the windows in
catfish be over just simple but they
have a nice render distance of course
they don't really lose too much detail
when you zoom out and they're not too
detailed they don't cause lag but they
also look pretty good and yes that's
just my opinion on those windows so i
would recommend anyone using those
things and at that point I was like yeah
I need to add something to that little
side thing over there but just decided
to go with a boring old over use window
that I've used 10,000 times in this park
I don't know if it's really a good idea
to over use a window like that but I
suppose I didn't have any other option
and then I decided to place a flat right
over here because this was an empty area
and I still don't have too many flat
rides in this bike if i remember
correctly i have the the woods a plane
call again it's called a Gravitron
rollercoaster tycoon because i just
played that but no it's called hiding in
a topspin yeah I think that's young is
the name it's except this one is telecon
or something like that and I think I
called the in game 1 Lancelot but anyway
I've got that right I've got the hopper
so that's 2 i've got the weird carousel
that's three and i think that's it
that's three flat rides that is
extremely underwhelming especially for a
park of this size so that's four with
this thing but i still definitely want
to add a small area with more of those
things because i have three roller
coasters and three roller coasters and
four flat rights doesn't really work out
i need many more flat rice in this bike
so unjustly where ever i can fit those
things in because i do like to go for a
kind of realistic flat ride / coaster
ratio despite not going for entire
realism in the spike I still do kind of
want to keep the attractions realistic
in that sense and this is going to be
the area where i want to add all those
flat rides perhaps a kids area i'm not
too sure about that i might also move
that and move that to another area what
I don't even have flat right except just
a playground and very small flat rides
like a carousel and a chair swing or
something like that and then call that a
kids area and basically I'm all over the
place especially with my time much
because at that point I was like nah I
don't want to work on that either and I
started working on a building over here
and that building by the way is not
going to serve any function i also have
no clue how i'm actually going to finish
that building the only thing that I
decided was I decided I'm going to build
a building over there and that's when I
started placing random shapes yeah
that's pretty much what I did over there
I have no idea that's actually going to
work out or if that was a good idea of
to Robert yeah that was just how i
decided to force myself to actually get
something in there because right now the
the thing that I have with this Pike is
I keep working on new things because i
have no DM like oh i should work in this
as well but then I just leave my other
thing unfinished so right now I left the
coaster unfinished on the station and
this building and the kids area even
that flat ride over there on top of the
hill next to the input so yeah loads of
things to do but i'll do that in the
next episode so see